film live il est 20h30 deux en retard de
deux minutes sur l'horaire annoncé
désolé mais nous sommes là pour sûr avec
vous cet événement le lancement de ce
soir de space x avec des invités
d'exception que je vais tout de suite
vous présenter en tout cas qui jouent
ensuite donné la parole puisque on vient
d'avoir l'information très importante
pour le lancement de ce soir c'est à
dire que pour le moment la météo
semblait nous sommes la positiver sur
vous cet événement le pierre-françois
bonsoir pierre françois mourier aux
journalistes à air et cosmos est
l'instigateur retransmettre ce live soit
c'est ça qu'on veut entendre c'est a
priori les conditions météos sort et
bonne écoute
a priori c'est bien parti alors il reste
encore un petit peu de temps avant le
lancement puisqu'il est prévu à 21h 22h
de paris et ça fait trois jours que les
conditions météo étaient quand même très
très incertaine avec une chance sur deux
seulement 50% de météo favorable et là
au dernier pointage météo comme on dit
tout et nominales et les voyants restent
au vert mais ça peut encore changer
voilà un peuple on a au nom n'a encore
que de longues minutes à attendre
et surtout ce qui sera crucial c'est le
moment où il
ils décideront de remplir les réservoirs
ou pas ce qui se fera 45 minutes avant
le scond appelle le h20 le moment du
décollage
oui car je suis frédéric castel kiel
avec nous également
durant ce jury se dire que si vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose juste sur
la météo j'ai couvert quelques dizaines
de lancement à cap canaveral quand je
n'y vais là-bas la météo juste à cap
canaveral à cause du golfe du mexique et
de l'atlantique est extrêmement instable
donc c'est une météo extrêmement
dynamique qui peut changer sans arrêt et
pour l'instant pour le thé 0 c'est
toujours ils craignent toujours là sur
deux convient d'indiquer et l'autre
point important c'est que c'est le site
météo le plus le plus précis au monde
par tous les moyens camille la nasa au
fil des décennies
donc il ya ils ont une vision 3d sur
100km absolument unique au monde en
moyens météo nous voyons donc en plein
écran cette fois cette fameuse capsule
qudra viennent au coeur de toutes les
discussions c'est donc à la capsule tu
va envoyer ce soir ce lanceur spi 6 donc
l'idée ce soit avec vous qui nous
rejoint dans le chat et que je salue un
autant le tchèque sur youtube de chasse
sur l'un des filiales en place et de
dialoguer avec vous de prendre vos
commentaires de prendre aux questions si
vous en avez de prendre en allait aussi
puisqu'on sait qu'il ya régulièrement
des spécialistes qui sont qui sont avec
nous aussi
aussi votre chatte je vais peut-être
laissé parole à un de ces spécialistes
avec nous ce soir dominique dominique
pétin justement pour parler peut-être de
cette capsule qu'on voit à l'image en ce
moment auquel les internautes voient en
plein écran
à ce moment qui est déjà occupée depuis
peu plus tard maintenant à part pas de
les deux astronautes
pourquoi est-ce que c'est d'elle dont on
parle tout le temps cette fameuse
capsule dragon de medica pas de lire
vous entend pas on communique pas deux
réponse oui oui un vrai beau commentaire
à faire je n'ai pas vraiment spécialiste
suis je suis membre de la société
astronomique de france et de la
commission assauts l'astronautique et
techniques spatiales dont l'eau pierre
françois et le président voilà chien
hurle sur la partie je connais un peu
l'histoire de l'astronautique sur la
partie précisément sur la capsule crown
agondjé pas vraiment de connaissances
pas si tu viens alors ce qu'on va faire
pour simplifier sa les connaissent trop
haut capable de répondre plus facilement
à ces questions alors dans ce cas là ce
qu'on va faire pour simplifier les
prises de parole je vais poser des
questions et commentaires des
internautes dans le tchat
et puis celui qui se sent de d'y
répondre il fait s'il est comme ça au
lieu de la parole comme ça il va pas
quand même par exemple on a seize
questions sur le chat qui est tout
simple une question de est gérée gère
qui le dit pourriez vous rappeler la
mission est le but de cette opération
commençons par le par le début le début
de la maison c'est rejoindre les ss
jean-pierre peut-être personne et cette
capsule servira aussi à des liaisons de
fret vers la station spatiale
internationale
donc elle est capable d'emporter jusqu'à
sept astronautes mais aujourd'hui le vol
qui nous qui nous occupe ce soir n'en
portera que deux astronautes
nous associons les 16 alors si on en
parle
pierre-françois c'est aussi parce que
c'est une première tout simplement pour
qu'on se paie six oui puisque la station
spatiale internationale qui comme son
nom l'indiqué et est international et
regroupe pas mal de pays dont les états
unis dont la russie dont japon dont
l'europe elle est occupée bientôt au
mois de novembre ça fera 20 ans qu'elle
est occupé en permanence et pour qui dit
occuper en permanence avec des rotations
à peu près 2 contre 3 y six mois pour
des équipages de trois personnes
il faut des vaisseaux pour les années
les équipages des vaisseaux habités et
puis des vaisseaux automatique aussi
pour leurs années de la nourriture du
fret des expériences et parmi
les vaisseaux qui amènent des équipages
il ya eu la navette spatiale américaine
qui ne vole plus depuis juillet 2011
à bientôt ferme devant pour plein de
raisons sa dangerosité son coup les
américains ont arrêté le programme
navette en 2011 et ont décidé de confier
à l'industrie privée
la conception des vaisseaux de
remplacement il ya deux vaisseaux qui
ont été retenus qui sont le starliner de
boeing qui est un peu en retard et le
crew dragon 2b 6 qui fait pour la
première fois aujourd'hui un vol avec
des hommes à bord et donc on parle du
premier vaisseau privé alors l'industrie
et le privé ont toujours été des sous
traitants de la nasa
mais là il ya quand même une délégation
d'un certain nombre de responsabilités
plus importantes qu'auparavant ce pour
ça qu'on parle de vol privé la nasa
insiste beaucoup sur cet aspect privé
est en tout cas spécifique va être la
première des deux sociétés avec boeing a
envoyé avec son un vaisseau qu'elle a
conçue en a commencé à travailler en
2014 donc c'est assez rapide en six ans
elle va pouvoir emmener ses alors
aujourd'hui c'est un vol de test avec
deux astronautes américains qui sont des
professionnels ou un cd ancien pilote au
cou ou spécialiste de charge utile de la
de la navette mais à terme elle pourra
envoyer aussi des touristes payant il ya
déjà des contrats qui ont été signés
avec des sociétés axium espérons
aventure parce p 6 donc on peut imaginer
que d'ici deux trois ans en plus des
rotations régulières assurées par le
star in einer de boeing ou d'une autre
ou dragon de spécifier aussi des vols
payants comme le soyouz russe a pu
accueillir de temps en temps on a eu
cette touriste américain international
on va dire qu'ils en qui ont volé depuis
depuis 2001 sur la station spatiale
internationale
allah nous sommes à 43 minutes de ce
décollage vous est riche et l'eau le
timer en plein écran sur sur ce live on
a une question qui revient alors la
caisse principale qui revient vous le
dis c'est qu'il heures le décollage on
va dire une confort tout il est prévu à
21 heures 22e on appris qu'ils allaient
se tenir un petit peu
on avance et pour l'instant on a aussi
une autre qui revient souvent c'est est
ce qu'on pourra voir la capsule la
capsule où elle a fusé depuis la france
est ce qu'on pourra la voir à l'oeil nu
peut-être ou avec avec une lunette
peut-être dans certaines régions de
france
parce que là entre vous à la
consommation gilles je pense micro micro
g alors effectivement on devrait pouvoir
alors on va voir la station spatiale
internationale
et comme vous le savez la station
spatiale internationale doit de se faire
rattraper en fait pour la capsule donc
la capsule micro dragonne
on pourra peut-être en avoir c'est pas
encore sûr et certain on va voir mais
effectivement il ya une forte
probabilité pour que ce soit le cas donc
je vais je peux regarder exactement pour
les habitants du nord de la france
ils ont la moitié nord de la france je
vais vous donner dans quelques instants
les éphémérides inexactes ce qu'il faut
en tout cas la station l on va l'avoir
passé gilles tu es jaloux dominé que
vous aviez indiqué l'horaire tout à
l'heure une sonde du passage de la
station elles ont la voix d'hier on l'a
vu passer enfin en ce moment elle passe
assez régulièrement tu la france oui
alors ce soir je donnais d'horaires pour
paris et un passage à 23h11 du courage à
l'ouest passe au sud est à 30 degrés au
dessus de l'horizon à 25,14 paraît
dessus des 76
on va dire la 24e heure 23h12 et 23h15
on pourra la voir à paris la france
les heures de paris merci beaucoup lui
tient son micro oui beaucoup de joueurs
du monde sont pas si on pourra les voir
à l'oeil nu mais quel équipement il faut
un nombre de taille pour pour vous pour
pouvoir suivre pour pouvoir suivre et
les fesses éventuellement est la fusée
si on veut gilles donc je viens de
regarder les éphémérides exact pour
coudre agon donc effectivement ce soir y
aura bien un passage à 23h16
direction donc il faut regarder vers
l'ouest à peu près à 10 degrés de
hauteur 10 degrés de hauteur au-dessus
de l'horizon ça veut dire que quand vous
tendez la main en fait la main le bras
tendu vous ouvrez la main entre les
pousser le petit doigt
ça ça fait 20 degrés d'accord donc le
bras tendu ça ça fait vingt degrés donc
c'est à peu près à la moitié et que vous
allez voir
effectivement la capsule crew dragonne
monté jusqu'à jusqu'à 18 degrés donc
c'est pas trés trés le ciel en direction
de l'ouest en direction du sud ouest
donc on va la voir que deux minutes
c'est très rapide en fait ça va de
l'ouest vers le sud ouest
ce soir et demain soir exactement la
même heure on la verra pas beaucoup plus
longtemps vous c'est malheureusement
c'est très fugace pour le moment voilà
donc pas d'équipement particulier à
l'oeil nu parce qu jumelles ça va très
très vite en fait et aux jumelles
finalement vous ne verrez pas grand
chose
donc il faut profiter du spectacle
avenue on peut même temps tu es un film
avec son smartphone sans trop de
difficultés voilà avons parfois dans vos
téléphones portables et c'est de la voir
si vous êtes sous la zone de passage
bien sûr parce qu'on a des gens qui nous
suivent de partout du canada par exemple
il salue bien sûr vous êtes nombreux
dans le chat ta bulle si beaucoup de
commentaires beaucoup de questions
notamment 7
cette question de rémy alors qu'on voit
les internautes
les astronautes pardon à l'image
sur le plan chevaux affiche on voit
également regarder vous avez juste en
bas le timer le décompte laon à 38
minutes et 20 secondes du décollage et
du coup cette question de leur ennemi
qui le monde pourquoi est ce que les
internautes rentrer dans la fusée aussi
longtemps avant c'est vrai que nous là
on a commencé ce direct plus de une
heure avant le décollage est en fait les
astronautes sont déjà dans la fusée
depuis depuis très très longtemps
alors pierre françois pourquoi alors
tout simplement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses à vérifier avoir des collages
et que la fusée au moment où il rentre
dedans n'est pas non plus rempli ce qui
est aussi une nouveauté est d'ailleurs
juste à noter au passage qui a cinq
minutes vous avez dû voir aussi à
l'image que le bras a été rétractées
c'est à dire de la fusée aller contre
une tour de une tour de lancement les
astronautes sont montés à l'aide des
ascenseurs se sont installés à bord de
la capsule est là maintenant que tout à
l'air de fonctionner on retire le bras
pour en attendant de remplir les
réservoirs je vous disais qui était une
manoeuvre importante et qui aura lieu
bah ça va pas tarder d'ici deux minutes
à moins de 35 minutes avant le décollage
et donc jusqu'à présent qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait ils se sont installés on à
vérifier l'étanchéité des scaphandres
des communications on a réglé leur siège
on a fermé la porte vérifier
l'étanchéité de la cabine
il y avait il ya des tas de procédure à
vérifier une dernière fois tout ça a
déjà été en plus répété maintes et
maintes fois il ya eu déjà une tentative
de lancement il ya trois jours et puis
quelques jours auparavant il y avait une
répétition générale
on n'est jamais dans l'improvisation
tout tout doit être répétée jusqu'au
moment du décollage et aujourd'hui ça
sera la grande nouveauté vraiment le
décollage
le remplissage du réservoir a déjà eu
lieu il ya trois jours puisqu'on avait
arrêté de compte à rebours à 17 minutes
avant le hajj 0 donc là on est bien
parti pour un remplissage c'est la
prochaine étape donc deux heures à
l'intérieur d'une cabine pour préparer
ces c'est pas trop chez les russes et
deux heures et demi à peu près la
navette ça devait être à peu près autant
peut-être s'en souvient
c'est vraiment pour vérifier que tout va
bien et on fait ça tranquillement avec
des listes très précise des check list
en anglais et d'ailleurs entre mercredi
aujourd'hui vont ils ont pris à peu près
cinq minutes d'avancé mais grosso modo
c'est les mêmes intervalles de temps
entre chaque opération et on chamboule
pas tout c'est très très rigoureux je me
souviens d'un astronaute qu'on avait
rencontré au centre européen des
astronautes en allemagne un escroc et
italiens qui disait c'est très simple
d'être astronaute en fait il suffit de
suivre les procédures mais ça c'est
important c'est vraiment les astronautes
vont préparer à toute éventualité
mais avant d'un tas de devoir justement
intervenir si besoin y respecte
scrupuleusement ce qu'on leur a demandé
de faire
nous sommes donc à vous le disais pas
fait soir environ 35 minutes de ce
lancement aura lieu à 21h26 les
conditions météo sont réunis bien sûr on
a beaucoup de questions je salue comme
toujours des gens qui nous qui nous
rejoignent dans le chat on à cette
question intéressante de martin qui a
bien noté que du coup la fusée partait
vers la station spatiale internationale
et qui vous demande simplement combien
de temps est-ce qu'elle va mettre pour
atteindre atteindre l' iss oui ma pierre
françois et bien a priori alors ça peut
être changé par rapport à mercredi mais
s'est on est sur 19 heures on on sera
assez rapidement tout à l'heure mais
voilà c'est moins d'une journée entre 19
et 24 heures je pense que le chiffre de
19 heures et toujours le bon donc en
fait le vaisseau va pas directement
rejoindre la station il va être d'abord
et demie sur une orbite temporaire un
petit peu moins ou de que la station
elle-même
et puis elle va la rejoindre avec eux
quelques poussées supplémentaires et
donc c'est demain en milieu d'après midi
qu'elle va s'approcher de la station et
s'y amarrer justement précisé ce que ce
que disait françois c'est à 16h30 que
devrait avoir lieu à quelques mètres et
le rendez-vous est automatique
d'ailleurs et juste avant
ils doivent se reposer sur manger et
s'entraîner à piloter en manuel
s'entraîner juste bien avant le rendez
vous de façon à ce que si un problème
pendant et vous en automatique il puisse
basculer et prendre des commandes
puisque ce genre de pilote d'essai et
deux anciens pilotes de navettes
spatiales à je précise pour les
internautes qui nous redonne que les
images que vous voyez en plein écran
actuellement dont ceux là ils sont bien
en direct et pour ceux qui se vendent
parce que j'ai dû passer les
commentaires ce sont des photos seins
jusque là caméra ne bouge pas que là on
arrive dans les dernières poignées de
minutes avant le décollage
et c'est le moment où évidemment j'ai
envie de dire plus rien ne doit bouger
plus rien de me dépasser
tout est vérifié les astreintes on les
voyait tout à l'heure eux non plus ne
bouge pas c'est normal ils attendent
maintenant le décollage comme nous en
fait
donc rassurez vous ce sont bien les
images en direct que vous voyez là sont
pas des foulées ou du dézonage alors je
vérifie que mon micro rit ça y est le
remplissage des réservoirs on est à 35
minutes du lancement
comme prévu le remplissage des
réservoirs a commencé et donc qu'il se
fasse au même moment où sont les
attraits d'abord ça c'est ça c'est
nouveau c'est une nouveauté spécifique
al qudra dragon spécifique celle en ce
moment là alors on a pas mal de
commentaires aussi messieurs sur les
combinaisons des astronautes les tenues
des astronautes
c'est quelque chose qui surprend pas mal
de monde c'est con à l'image d'épinal
l'image d'épinal des des combinaisons
apollo très bouffantes très très vive un
d'un mais là on avait des combinaison
d'astronaute plus fine avec des casques
voilà des visières beaucoup plus visible
que vous buvez beaucoup mieux les voir
car en beaucoup plus aux combinaisons
qu'on peut voir dans mass effect 1 pour
ceux qui s'intéressent aux jeux vidéo
quelque chose de plus moderne et
pourtant messieurs ces combinaisons
elles elles ne font pas forcément
l'unanimité
j'ai cru comprendre en tout cas en tout
cas en tout cas parmi vous
déjà expliqué pourquoi les combinaisons
qu'on voit aujourd'hui ne sont plus
celles qu'on voyait à durant les années
60 et 70
stéphane peut-être stéphane tu peux nous
expliquer un peu les différents types de
combinaisons alors pour l'acro aragón
effet avoue des combinaisons très légère
trafic donc qui change totalement de la
conception des combines durant l'avant
parce que par exemple si vous souvenez
de la des combinaisons de la navette
spatiale
c'étaient les combinaisons orange et il
y avait un rôle un peu particulier et tu
n'es pas les mêmes contraintes sur la
coupe aragón donc sur à coudre à
grandmont n'est plus une combinaison de
l'économie russe est tombée dans son col
et tant qu'à faire des combinaisons du
titre russes ont fait des drones dans
l'ultra léger ultra à tout aussi
performante apps le but est de protéger
les équipages pendant que la maman de
nicolas jusque-là film démonte et
pendant le retour c'est pas des kouriles
en fait françois recevoir l'aide pas
donc c'est pour ça qu'elles sont moins
imposante inclinaison là il y en a
besoin uniquement pour les phases de
montées et de descentes et donc on a vu
à plutôt envisager de de faire des
combinaisons légères cycling north au
col rouge
mais à la différence c'est que bach
comme seven losc tant qu'à faire il faut
qu'il joue mobile des prisons est un peu
la classe et donc pour ce faire il a
demandé un designer total de décès ou
maisons donc dès le gp sont en tête des
meneurs qui a fait les combinaisons pour
des semaines c'est trop de lacunes pour
zone 2 de wolverine
donc c'est pour ça que ces combinaisons
ont un petit côté très futuriste mais il
faut pas
tract était à son os et fonctionnel que
les combinaisons à l'antenne mais à sont
simplement plus moderne à son bras
bouquet ans partait en 3d notamment le
cac
on voit toute la partie arrière du
théâtre la partie blanche et de la
fabrication 3d est le déçu et un tissu
très léger 10 bat le poids et qu'elles
soient pas reporter le lancement quelque
chose d'un peu de combinaisons alors
françois je crois que je crois que vous
avez débranché votre micro ou que en
tout cas on entend beaucoup moins next
alors non on entend de manière lointaine
merci gilles on peut même rajouter que
elon musk d'il ya quatre ans avec ce
designer pour mettre au point ce
scaphandre qui était un peu son rêve de
voilà bah scaphandre science-fiction
hollywoodien et et qui fonctionne qui
répondent aux normes de des vols habités
de spécifier de la nasa est alors pour
les connaisseurs comme vous qu'est ce
que ça a évolué coup ces combinaisons
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
important le design des combinaisons
sais c'est pour le ces pour le spectacle
c'est pour la corse alors connaissant
elon musk s'il ya beaucoup de spectacle
il faut juste espérer que en cas de
nécessité puisque ce sont des
combinaisons qui doivent stéphane à 10 1
qui sont pas destinés à sortir hors de
la capsule dans le vide de l'espace
assez d'autres combinaisons qu'on
appelle des combinaisons de sortie
extravéhiculaire qui sont des mini
vaisseaux spatiaux miniature en fait
complètement indépendant là ça permet
juste en cas de dépressurisation ou d'un
incendie à bord de survivre pendant
quelques instants et de rentrer en
urgence
donc faut espérer que le look n'est pas
allé au détriment de n'importe enfin de
la sécurité mais c'est vrai que pourquoi
elles sont nouvelles dans votre la
question de départ d'un internaute sait
aussi que ça fait partie du lot sp6 a
construit une capsule avec un nouveau
scaphandre
c'est un nouveau un nouveau modèle les
deux vont ensemble et c'est pas rien
starliner les astronautes qui vont
monter dans les capsules de boeing sont
vont en utiliser d'autres d'autres
scaphandre je n'ai pas si on voit un
petit peu ma figurine je suis un peu
dans la pénombre
voilà qui elles sont un petit peu plus
traditionnel on va dire les scaphandres
bleus de boeing ils sont un peu plus
ample il ressemble davantage à ce qu'on
a connu jusqu'à présent mais en tout cas
les on a profité effectivement pour les
moderniser les relooker nous sommes à 26
minutes maintenant un petit peu plus de
26 minutes
du décollage a annoncé de cette fusée
que vous voyez que vous suivez avec nous
depuis par une petite trentaine de
minutes
maintenant on continue toujours à
prendre vos questions vos commentaires
vous êtes nombreux à sur le chat tout ça
lui joue pas tous vous saluer bien
évidemment as visuellement mais bien
évidemment vous êtes tous dans mon coeur
les internautes se soit on à cette
question de lolo mots qui nous parle de
l'impact écologique de ce genre de
décollage alors moi j'ai envie de vous
demander monsieur je ne sais pas si la
nôtre vous le laissiez de fusées
spécifique par rapport à d'autres excuse
aux impacts écologiques et se sont plus
fortes que les autres et ce qu'ils sont
plus ou moins polluante que vous avez
une l'idée de ça pas facile à dire
amérique mais les falcons et toutes les
fusées de la nasa en général et je suis
fier de ceux ci donc même si un tout
petit peu de kérosène sont absolument
pas polluante c'est quasiment il ya très
très peu de pollution et je vous
rappelle que sur le site de cap
canaveral
c'est l'un des parcs naturels les plus
grands ou de la côte est des états unis
et c'est la plus belle collection
d'oiseaux sur toute la côte est des
états unis est précisément cap canaveral
plus les alligators puisque la faune
dans tous les sens donc ce n'est
absolument pas ce n'est pas ce n'est
absolument pas polluant à l'époque du
shuttle les boosters il y avait de la
poudre et la poudre dès fois se déposer
sur les voitures nous faisait mal aux
yeux
voilà aujourd'hui c'est donc c'est
extrêmement concluant spatiale en
général est très peu polluant
une question qui va peut-être vous
surprendre qui est vraiment d'actualité
séparés en question mais c'est beaucoup
d'internautes qui commande sur le sur le
corona virus et qui pose la question
peut-être un parfois on règle un petit
peu mais là elle a un fond assez sérieux
c'est comment on fait pour s'assurer que
les instructions sont pas malades du
courant nature ou tout autre chose parce
que quand on part comme ça dans l'espace
puis
justement comment est ce qu'ils ont ils
sont testés comment est-ce qu'on détecte
qui vont pas tomber malade dans les
fesses du coup ne pas avoir de pouvoir
bénéficier de ce bourg pierre françois
et bien en fait comme de la manière dont
on traite où on essaye de d'éradiquer le
coran dit vieux coronavirus en france et
dans le monde
on a mis en place des quarantaines et
les astronautes sont rentrés en
quarantaine quand il était encore à
houston avant d'arriver en floride le
personnel qui les encadre et extrêmement
prudent donc port du masque
distanciation sociale et compagnie je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué tous les
lignes ja qui avait autour des deux
astronautes l'a habillé en noir et ils
ont tous un masque et tout le monde a
été testé et il ya vraiment une alors
avant le coronavirus il y avait déjà une
habitude depuis toujours depuis le vol
de gagarine
les personnels des cosmonautes et
astronautes sont mis en quarantaine et
les personnels font attention donc là
maintenant on a redoublé d'efforts
effectivement depuis le précédent
lancement du d'un soyouz au mois de mars
où là il y avait eu aucune famille
présente en russie
pas de presse très très peu de
techniciens voilà et le but du jeu c'est
que les astres ne tombent pas malades et
ne mènent pas non plus le virus à bord
de la station où les attendent trois
autres astronautes pour pas que tout le
monde tombe mal après il faut pas
dramatiser ainsi être autre autre homme
malade il ya des moyens médicaux à bord
et puis en cas de vraiment grands
problèmes un astronaute ça sera patrie
en quelques heures sur terre et du coup
cette cette question en entraîne
entraîne une autre c'est l'entraînement
plus globale les internes alors on a
plusieurs personnes désolé j'ai pas le
temps si tvo non le chat de filtrer très
vite mais je vois je vois vos questions
les repères du juste pas le cas cité ou
non on a eu une plusieurs même plusieurs
commentaires sur l'entraînement des
astronautes
bon là il est très très longue c'est
difficile à résumer comme ça mais dans
les grandes lignes
gilles quelques ailes prérequis il faut
pour pour être un bon astronomiques et
beaucoup de jeunes aussi dans chat
peut-être qu'il ya des vocations a
suscité alors d'abord d'abord
effectivement il faut ils ont tous des
parcours
académique on va dire universitaire et
d'écoles d'ingénieurs très solides
ils sont tous très sportif donc ça sera
un peu des lieux communs à l'isem
évidemment laventure mais ils ont tous
pratiqué des sports comme la plongée le
parachutisme souvent ce sont des pilotes
pour l'essentiel ce sont tous des
ingénieurs il ya des scientifiques aussi
évidemment mais globalement la ce soir
nos deux astronautes sont là en
l'occurrence donc non seulement des
astronautes déjà aguerris puisqu'ils ont
tous les deux déjà deux vols en commun
alors il n'avait pas volé ensemble
maison de vol chacun dans la station
spatiale à bord de l'ancien navette
américaine donc et mêmes des sorties
extravéhiculaires dans l'espace donc ce
sont vraiment des gens très aguerris et
très bien formés mais surtout ce sont
d'anciens pilotes des
lieutenants-colonels de l' us air force
où des marines et du coup donc ils sont
aguerris donc sont des astronautes
pilote de chasse et là en l'occurrence
ce sont des instants des astronautes
pilote d'essai en fait puisque c'est pas
un vol régulier ce vol là et quand même
encore on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'objectif de la mission
l'objectif de la mission s'est certes
d'aller dans la station spatiale
internationale
mais c'est de valider complètement que
la capsule crew tarragone et bien est
solide et fiable robuste et conforme
complètement aux objectifs
donc ils prennent un risque parce que
encore plus si vous me permettez que que
les autres vols classiques c'est la
première fois qu'on teste crew dragonne
avec des personnes à bord et c'est
précisément pour cela qu'on met que deux
personnes et non pas quatre cinq six ou
sept
voilà donc beaucoup d'études et puis
surtout après il faut être très patient
puisque les deux n'ont pas volé depuis
très très longtemps
presque dix ans en fait voyez donc entre
entre le premier vol est le deuxième vol
par exemple pour bob behnken il ya eu
deux ans c'était entre 2008 et 2010
vous vous rendez compte que nous sommes
en 2020 ça fait dix ans qu'il n'a pas
volé et puis pour douglas hurley et bien
un premier voile en 2009 deuxième vol en
donc là aussi ça fait presque dix ans ça
fait neuf ans qu'il n'a pas volé donc
beaucoup de patience et puis un
entraînement physique sportif se sont
pas des des jeunes gens - et la poésie
dans la cinquantaine n'a eu qu'à 49 ans
l'autre à 50 3 ans donc vous voyez ce
sont des vétérans comme on le dit des
vétérans très solide physiquement et
mentalement nous sommes à moins de 20
minutes maintenant de ce décollage alors
en vigueur sur le direct puisque là on
voit de la fumée qui est en train de
s'échapper de la de la fusée ce qu'on
peut décrire ce qu'ils entrent à se
passer puisque maintenant on entre
vraiment dans les étapes cruciales
messieurs pierre françois oui je disais
que donc le remplissage a lieu oxygénée
et qui rosen qui sont des des gaz
liquéfiés et donc pour liquéfier à gazon
le refroidit et là c'est tout simplement
la différence de température qui
provoque tout toute cette fumée
c'est de la vapeur d'eau un peu tout
simplement le lanceur les réservoirs à
l'intérieur est rempli de donc de deux
d'ergo liquide extrêmement froid de
l'ordre de moins de 100 200 degrés donc
bas a priori tout se passe bien le camp
les réservoirs seront pleins il ya
toujours un peu des babouins
d'évaporation donc on continue
régulièrement les cordons ombilicaux
vraiment jusqu'au dernier moment sont
attachés à la fusée pour continuer à
remplir ainsi jamais le réservoir se
vider un tout petit peu mais on continue
à rajouter des ergols jusqu'au dernier
moment et au moment du décollage des
cordons ombilicaux vont être les uns
après les autres
détaché et le lanceur va s'élancer donc
maintenant on est effectivement à 18 18
minutes ça se précise
rappelons simplement que mercredi
à un peu moins 17 minutes on avait
annulé pour des problèmes de prévision
de météo donc là voilà on va te faire
mieux que mercredi pour l'instant on
entre dans la 17e minute avant ce
décollage de plus en plus nombreux à me
suivre sur cette affaire si je salue
bien sûr j'ai vu j'ai vu malgré la
rapide des commentaires la question de
batman 51 qui voudraient eux qui finance
ce projet alors on parle beaucoup de
l'es6 pour paraître la nasa ce qu'on
peut expliquer la base de comment
comment ils financer un projet comme
celui-ci stéphane puisqu'il ya la nasa
qui impliquait y avait six est ce qu'on
peut préciser ça wily en fait tu éteins
c'est un thème la nada on leur avait
préparé en 2011 a demandé à fait comme
un système de concours a demandé à des
sociétés ils ont dit voilà on va vous
vous ne vivez créé en moi un vaisseau
spatial capable d'amener des hommes soit
à son spot à nous livrer clé en main
avec traîné son système de lancement et
à partir de là vous pourrez avoir le
marché donc il ya eu plusieurs conclure
plusieurs industriels se sont présentés
et les deux qui ont remporté le marché
on va dire et boeing pour les vols
habités à un troisième terrain et lada
ue avait une petite navette et qui ne
pourra renvoyer vers son hôte mais
fournit avec encore du cerveau donc en
fait c'est steve blake a été proposée
par la nasa vous livrer clés en main un
système complet permettant d'envoyer des
astronautes dans la façon spatiale et
vous aurez le contrat est donc la nasa a
choisi les deux finales et on est
vraiment là aux femmes du chat ptx nous
poussera la paix réalité 2 sans argent
et donc des commandes que la nahdha nous
appâter qu'à partir du moment où ce vol
sera validée c'est pour ça que j verdict
était important
cette mission puisque ces finissants
validation de la qualité du concept nous
ce que tu pourrais
vous à 15 minutes maintenant quinze
minutes cinq ans messieurs j'ai envie de
vous dire je vais passer les images en
grand le ciel est clair en tout cas le
ciel s'était éclairci par rapport à tout
à l'heure
évidemment c'est pas c'est pas nous
devant notre écran nous pouvons définir
les conditions météo sur place en
floride mais ces bons scores en tout cas
c'est visuellement en tout cas il ya des
conditions météo se sont se sont
améliorées depuis
depuis tout à l'heure en tout cas depuis
le moment où on a même on a même
commencé cela est beau mouvement ces
deux c'est de bonne augure bien françois
alors attention après il faut moi j'ai
assisté à des lancements en guyane ou au
sol il faisait extrêmement beau et
depuis longtemps et ça n'avait pas l'air
de bouger dans le futur et le lancement
a quand même été annulée parce que il
n'ya pas que la sortie de rampes qui est
importante il ya aussi tout le trajet
jusqu'à la mise sur orbite et tout ce
qui concerne la retombées possibles de
la capsule en cas de défaillance en cas
de d'annulation d'abandon de mission
prématurée la fusée équipés de petites
fusées de détresse qui peuvent être
affectés la capsule et les deux
astronautes en cours de l'ascension
et là il faut qu'il retombe pas dans des
zones où les équipes peuvent aller les
chercher et où la météo doit être assez
clémente donc il ya il ya des plaintes
critères il ya au moins cinq violations
à ne pas dépasser
en présence de nuages de d'électricité
dans l'air de vitesses de vent et et
compagnie et donc c'est pas parce que au
sol ou à l'image on peut avoir
l'impression qu'il fait beau que
finalement les conditions météo sont
sont bonnes partout après ce qu'on a vu
sur les derniers écrans
c'est qu'a priori bas tout était quand
même vers et était bien parti là pour le
13 minutes qui restent devant nous on a
plusieurs passants qu'ils interrogent
sur les sur les risques je pense que
c'est la vision de fumée blanche qui
s'est échappé de la fusée qui fait dire
à tout le monde
voilà ça y est en train de se passer à
ce stade quels sont les risques c'est la
question qui est posée à tel quel dans
l'autre ça par bright tout seul gilles
ulrich peut-être frédéric vous entendez
là où eux tout lancement implique un
risque mais la révolution là par rapport
à la navette où il ya eu deux accidents
qui ont tué 14 astronautes
il ya beaucoup moins de risques avec une
fusée traditionnelle et une capsule
éjectable convient d'expliquer et donc
les risques sont bien moins on les
évalue à une chance sur deux cent
soixante dix la probabilité d'un
accident évalué par la nasa alors que
sur le shuttle sur la navette c'est
évalué à une chanson 70 de perdre
l'équipage qui malheureusement a été le
cas donc les deux fois donc beaucoup
moins risqué mais toujours du risque
s'est pas prendre un train que de partir
dans l'espace
nous sommes 20 maintenant 22 13 minutes
avant ce décollage il voulu ajouter
quelque chose oui en terme de risque il
faut pas oublier que finalement les les
c'est comme en avion la partie les deux
parties les plus risquées c'est ce sont
vraiment le décollage et le retour on
n'a jamais perdu dans toute l'histoire
de l'exploration spatiale
on n'a jamais perdu d'équipage dans
l'espace on a toujours eu des accidents
graves et mortels dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
donc soit au à l'aller soit au retour
c'est très important de le noter
une question que je trouve très
intéressante
deux trios knicks sur le chat qui
manquent est-ce que les propulseurs ou
d'autres éléments de la fusée seront
récupérées comme le voulait ce pays 6 je
pense qu'on a tous en tête ces images
2 justement des propulsions qui se
repose et 6eme vous avait décollé
spécifique saleh avait énormément
communiquer communiquer là dessus est ce
que ce sera le cas là tout simplement
françois oui priori aujourd'hui le
laitage et 9
le premier étage est neuf et doit
dizaine douzaine de minutes après après
le décollage redescendre au dessus de la
mer et se poser en douceur sur une barge
avec toujours le sens de l'humour delmas
qui s'appelle of corse à estinnes love
you bien sûr je t'aime toujours et donc
on va suivre ce décollage en direct dans
onze minutes maintenant 11 minutes et 20
secondes vous voyez les deux astronautes
américains sur ces images vous voyez un
petit à petit geste des doubles d'un
désastre
je ne sais pas si c'est une forme de
morale de concentration c'est assez
c'est assez intéressant à voir forcément
l'instant est crucial pour eux on est à
onze minutes de ce décollage de la fusée
qui va partir vers l'ieseg emmené ses
deux astronautes américains vers l'iss
est double à ce relais et robert behnken
vous êtes très nombreux à nous suivre et
on vous remercie
sur sur figaro live et sur la chaîne
youtube du client vous êtes tellement
d'embauché j'ai du mal à suivre sur tous
vos commentaires objet de passer en
ralenti pour pour pour pouvoir
l'éprouvant jédir on a renault sur le
chat d'ailleurs qui nous pose une
question sur le tourisme spatial ont un
peu évoquée on sait que pour pour
spécifier c'est quelque chose de
d'important la question c'est 70 est ce
que ça va ça va devenir ou est-ce qu'en
tout cas à l'échelle d'une vie mais non
on peut voir devenant le tourisme
spatial quelque chose de deux mois je
passe bien méritée mais en tout cas de
deux courants de fréquents est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce que dans les deux
années à venir on est vraiment des gens
qui ont les moyens forcément le ça coûte
cher partir mais vraiment très
régulièrement commun comme certains
partent par week-end c'est un peu de
c'est un petit pas question de
prospective mais quand on voit des
compagnies privées comme le space x
force et avec tellement de train d'enfer
dans cette conquête sociale je pense que
la question se pose mais ne vous inspire
pas j'ai l'impression messieurs si j'ai
le plus fragile j'ai vu ouidah écoutez
le en fait faux bond la réalité quand
même c'est que aujourd'hui
d'abord il faut avoir une condition
physique exceptionnelle c'est pas du
tourisme comme on l'a sur terre on a
parlé des risques tout à l'heure ok ils
sont quand même maîtrisé grâce à
technologie mais ça reste quand même une
démarche de professionnels qui sont
entraînés pendant on l'a dit déjà dix
quinze vingt ans parfois pour arriver à
ce niveau d'excellence de maîtrise
totale certes là il ya deux personnes à
bord de la capsule mais il ya des
dizaines de milliers d'ingénieurs de
scientifiques de techniciens qui ont
travaillé pendant très très longtemps
donc ce n'est pas des avions de ligne ou
des trains ou des voitures
c'est quand même beaucoup plus
sophistiqué donc moi je ne crois pas un
tourisme de masse avant des centaines
d'années
donc voilà il faut être un peu réaliste
malheureusement je vais peut-être faire
de la peine ou tuer quelques quelques
désillusions
après il y aura il ya déjà eu des
touristes effectivement des gens très
fortunés qui sont capables de payer 20
ou 35 40 millions de dollars pour
quelques jours dans la station spatiale
ou dans une station spatiale ou en
orbite bon ça va peut-être se multiplier
effectivement il n'est pas interdit de
penser que même pour à un petit peu
moins cher peut-être dix fois moins cher
un jour ou l'autre on puisse faire du
tourisme en orbite est puni en dessous
de cela il y aura des sauts de puce donc
pour peut-être quelques centaines de
milliers d'euros de dollars
on pourra faire juste un saut de puce
c'est à dire monter à 100 km d'altitude
et est retombé sur terre donc le vol ne
durera que quelques minutes en tout et
puis que quelques dizaines de secondes
en apesanteur à 100 km avant de
retrouver le plancher des vaches
voilà où nous en sommes en fait il est
peu probable qu'il y ait un touriste à
tourisme
au-delà de cela par exemple un tourisme
sur la lune ça c'est pas envisageable
avant très très longtemps
par exemple nous sommes à sept minutes
du décollage les choses se précisent
qu'ils pourraient encore être annulés et
pierre françois à oui biensur oui oui
tout à fait il réservé trois ont jusqu'à
trois secondes avant le décollage ça
peut ça peut être annulé juste pour
rebondir ce que sur ce que disait gilles
en termes de chiffres puisque
aujourd'hui s'il est accessible aux
personnes fortunées et en bonne santé il
faut être donc en très bonne santé et
très très fortunés l'insp et 6 qui est
censé casser les prix sur le coup dragon
a priori alors oh c'est pas officielle
mais en faisant des recoupements
on chiffre on estime le siège à 50
millions de dollars pour la nasa et à
peu près autant pour des touristes et il
ya une société au mois de mars qui
s'appelle axium que j'ai cités tout à
l'heure qui a négocié d'emmener à partir
de là du second semestre 2021 donc ça
c'est dans un an
quatre touristes accompagnés enfin trois
touristes accompagnés par un ancien
astronaute de la nasa
et là il perd et ça serait un forfait
lancement plus séjour d'une semaine à
bord de l' iss on parle encore de 55
millions de dollars
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
un budget et pour les vols plus rapide
suborbitaux dont parlait gilles
aujourd'hui on est à des tarifs qui sont
pareils et papa officielle mais qui sont
estimés à 200 250 mille dollars pour un
vol de moins de 10 minutes
donc voyez ça reste ce qui reste
accessible aujourd'hui si vous voulez
connaître la sensation d'apesanteur ce
sont les vols en avion zéro g et la
compagnie de novespace française propose
avec la société est rasé roger des vols
des campagnes d'une vingtaine de
paraboles chacun parabole durant une
trentaine de secondes
et là ce n'est plus que six mille euros
que 6000 euros
effectivement alors là on est amené à
5032 ceux de ce décalage
on a toujours beaucoup de questions
beaucoup de commentaires océane ou
demande combien de g qu'ils prennent au
décollage
est-ce qu'on fait ça messieurs la
pression qui s'exerce rue est ce que
vous l'avez en tête
est ce que c'est la réussira à coller
nos spéciale ce soir sur le sur le
décollage
jean-françois oui je pense qu'on est
dans les specs traditionnel ça doit être
3,4 g au maximum alors sachant que quand
il ya un souci est que les moteurs de
sauvetage sont allumés pour une
déjection là en revanche c'est beaucoup
plus violent et on monte à du 15 20 g il
ya des cosmonautes russes qui ont été
complétés éjecté et même américains il
ya deux ans donc là ça ça fait mal mais
au décollage normalement tout est fait
pour que ça soit relativement progressif
et que ça dépasse pas 3,4 g ce qui pour
un pilote de chasse comme un pilote
d'essai comment comme visage il est
vraiment ce sont des gens qui est qui
ont des heures d entraînement et une
habitude de voile beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus
on va dire j ride comme dirait michel et
alors là messieurs nous sommes à quatre
minutes de ce décollage on va commencer
à parler - ou simplement un joli 10 dans
le dos le chat puisqu'on va commencer à
savourer l'instant avec vous je vais
vous mettre progressivement le sont sur
place vous allez pouvoir entendre comme
nous le sont toujours très présents le
décompte fameux décompte qu'on devrait
on devrait pouvoir entendre aussi c'est
bien sûr le vol des passionnés de
françois me disais que jusque jusqu'au
bout le vol peut être annulée nous
sommes maintenant vous le voyez sur le
timer à 3 minutes 40 de ce décollage
voyait toujours les deux astronautes à
l'image est toujours et toujours
toujours ces petits mouvements de demain
de voir une façon pour eux à ce stade là
j'ai envie de dire que les préparatifs
sont là c'est peu à 3 minutes évidemment
on peut faire marche arrière j'aurais le
dire pour eux puisque certains se
posaient la question dans le tchad
rapidement on a quand même ce lesage
diallo de janvier donc il est combien de
temps qu'ils vont rester dans l'île
c'est ce qu'on pourra durer leur mission
dès qu'ils seront là bas jean-françois
alors ça c'est un peu une inconnue c'est
étonnant c'est peut-être la première
fois que deux astronautes se prépare
pour un vol dont ils connaissent pas la
durée pourquoi parce qu'on connaît pas
encore les capacités complètes du
vaisseau notamment en termes de
d'alimentation électrique les panneaux
c'est la première fois qu'ils vont être
utilisés sur un vol long et on sait pas
s'ils vont subir des sabines et
rapidement ou pas grosso modo ils
partent entre un et quatre mois il
espère vous volez au moins un mois à
bord de l'iss est ce le maximum étant
cent dix neuf jours ils devraient
rentrer le 20 septembre si au mieux si
tout aussi tout va bien sachant que le
vaisseau dragon coup dagon à terme
l'huile il est prévu pour 210 jours au
maximum
voilà
donc c'est entre entre 4,4 et ciment
comme le soyouz après le vaisseau
s'abîmer il faut il faut il faut les
faire entrer entrée sur terre j'en
profite juste pour parce que je sais
qu'il nous regarde et il ya une classe
qui est une classe espace à la norville
qui est extrêmement motivé qui est
connecté et qui nous regardent et qui
qui est toujours passionnée et
passionnante
je sais pas s'ils ont posé des questions
en tout cas on peut pas répondre à tout
le monde mais voilà on voulait en tout
cas stéphane gillet mois saluer nos
jeunes amis de la dent ville et leur
extraordinaire professeur l'or voilà une
minute quarante maintenant de de ce
décollage ont leurs coûts
messieurs juste avant de laisser le
sceau de l'événement prendre provolo
passion son commentaire est ce qu'on
peut expliquer ce train de se passer là
hors de l'eau qui est en train de couler
de ce réservoir est ce qu'on peut
décrire tout simplement ce qui est près
d'arriver
jean-françois oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
le déluge c'est à dire qu avant
l'allumage des moteurs pour refroidir
enfin c'est surtout pour protéger le pas
de tir contre contre les flammes
on envoie de l'eau qui vont qui sait
tout va servir vraiment d'amortisseur il
ya juste aussi oui c'est pour éviter les
vibrations hausse il ya des vibrations
énorme au décollage acoustique et pour
éviter qu'elle ne détruise le lanceur on
vient faire un masque avec de l'eau et
s'ils ont la vue même tombé sur une des
caméras qui filmaient c'est pour ça que
j'ai changé dax de caméras à moins d'une
minute maintenant de ce décollage on va
le vivre ensemble
je vais progressivement monter le son
original de la vidéo pour que nous
puissions souvent sans le décompte
monsieur juste en 20 secondes est ce qu
on peut rappeler est ce qu'on va voir la
fusée de la france et où et comment
j'aime beaucoup jean clément dans le
tchat oui on pourra voir la fusée vers
23h 16 à 23h11 enverra la station
spatiale et à 23h16 là
non pas la fusée mais crew dragonne à 10
degrés ouest
il faut regarder vers l'ouest à 23h au
nom des 23 16 ce décompte
quelqu'un a vu ma pipe
[Applaudissements]
c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas de l'image
de haller de l'intérieur c'est curieux
d'ailleurs
et aussi pour ça avec
m
[Musique]
j'imagine qu'elle soit 58 secondes c'est
le passage max qse le maximum de
pression dynamique c'est à dire c'est au
moment où le lanceur est soumise de
vibrations et cause de l'accélération de
la pression de l'air
c'est un bon rôle de lanceur pour
risques à se briser ses frais un peu
comme le passage du bac
[Musique]
pour l'instant c'est nominal alors on a
très brièvement les internautes est
dommage c coupé ça c'est normal c'était
attendu c'est vrai que séparation
[Musique]
séparation réussie peuple et les images
à l'intérieur au lancement sont une
nouveauté qui vient que des russes et
donc les américains sont assez frileuses
sur ce sujet parce qu'il veut pas qu'ee
un problème est que ce soit filmée en
direct monde y est toujours et un débat
sur l'utilisation de ces caméras alors
chez les russes c'est courant mais là
tout est de nominal et donc je crois
quand même que les astronautes en un
contrôle sur cette caméra on la met ou
pas la mettre à leur discrétion pousse
le sol et là on voit les images
le lanceur large de terre-neuve au
canada qui se dirigeait vers l'école
c'est comme ça qu'on pourra la voix un
peu plus tard au dessus du nord de la
france
donc là le premier étage a fini de sa
mission il a été largué doigt qu'on a vu
la séparation la saison voit on voit
bien le moteur du deuxième étage qui est
à droite de l'image qui on voit que la
tuyère commence à être rouge à cause de
la chaleur
donc si une fusée à deux étages c'est le
deuxième étage qui va terminer la
mission qui va terminer la mise sur
orbite
et pendant ce temps là le mal premier
étage là qu'est ce qui fait en ce moment
il est en train de tomber
il va faire une manoeuvre avec son
moteur qui a permis au décollage est
encore assez d'ergols pour faire une
petite manoeuvre de retournement et de
déployer des sortes de grille de
ralentissement est retombé est avec des
petits acomptes des rétros freinage de
son moteur il va redescendre jusqu'à la
plate-forme et s'y poser normalement
alors là il ya aussi des caméras qui
sont qui sont sur la plate forme
offshore still love you et on devrait
voir il faut à peu près une dizaine de
minutes pour que que le premier étage
redescendre et vient de se poser la
barge est situé à peu près au nord-est
de cap kennedy 500 km en mer voilà
messieurs nous sommes d'ailleurs très
peu de temps voir pas délibération du
tout à l'intérieur plus de 50 cl sur
cela il a profité de ces images a
profité de vos commentaires pierre
françois oui alors ce qui est vraiment
extraordinaire
c'est c'est effectivement donc
apparemment tout tout à l'air calme à
bord de la station la caméra bouge pas
les astronautes sont il n'y avait alors
aucune vibration ça a l'air d'être
smoothie comme diraient les américains
et puis ce qui est surtout incroyable
c'est que finalement les ce vaisseau a
décollé à la deuxième tentative et la
première tentative a été annulée à cause
de la météo
c'est à dire qu'en termes de maîtrise
technique des préparatifs il n'y a pas
eu un seul arrêt chrono ce qui est quand
même très fréquent surtout sur un
vaisseau qui voile pour la première fois
il ya toujours un capteur défaillant ou
en tout cas une petite alerte le temps
de comprendre il faut bouter un
ordinateur et là ça fait quand même deux
fois que ce p6 déroule la chronologie
qui a commencé plus de quatre heures à
il ya plus de quatre heures
et voilà il ya une maîtrise technique
quand même chez space x qui a une
entreprise qu'on parle qu'on qualifie
encore de start up
on est quand même six mille personnes
mais qui n'a que 10 ans ce qui dans le
dans le spatial est assez récent je
rajouterais parce que à ce que tu dis
c'est que aussi on voit là on a quitté
la l'époque du château qui est l'engin
volant le plus complexe jamais construit
par l'homme et là on revient
heureusement un système beaucoup plus
simple et donc effectivement c'est à
l'honneur bien sûr de spe 6 mais il ya
beaucoup moins de possibilités de bugs
d'anomalies et de défaillance sur une
fusée qirshi cas toujours recherchés la
simplicité et ça c'est un peu le génie
de l'équipe space x et de lots de
masques de revenir au classique de des
lanceurs et des fusées et le plus rêver
aux lanceurs et les pommes l'avion
spatial qui était la dette ce qui est
magnifique là c'est qu'on voit sur
l'image de droite
le premier étage qui s'apprête à
atterrir à nouveau sur la planète en
fait sur sa barre voyez la maîtrise
technologique dont pierre françois a
parlé à quelques instants on voit des
petits coups de moteurs latéraux et puis
à gauche la rotondité de la terre sur ce
retour maîtrisé de spe 6 faut juste
savoir que 20 il faut se rappeler que ce
p 6 est la seule entreprise au monde qui
est capable de le faire
est-ce que ça a un intérêt outre la
prouesse technologique c'est un autre
débat est-ce que ça permet d'économiser
des coûts tout le monde on n'est pas
certain le modèle économique de ce fait
6 et pas très transparent on va dire
mais en tout cas d'un point de vue
technique technique c'est admirable ce
sont les seuls à le faire ils le font
depuis décembre 2015
et là je crois qu'on doit être à la 52e
le 52e atterrissage de depuis décembre
2015 c'est quand même quasiment
systématique avec un taux d'échec qui
doit être de 5 pour cinq ans et c'est
vraiment un tour de force technologique
qui impressionne tout le monde là le
premier étage il va rentrer dans la
couche nuageuse donc vous voyez on doit
on doit être à une dizaine ou une
quinzaine de kilomètres d'altitude
maximum avec une coupure une coupure de
la caméra les abords du premier étage et
à propos des coupures de caméras de
temps en temps l'image se coupent bassa
faut savoir que la fusée d'avancé quand
même très très vite
en fin de mission elle sera à 8 km par
seconde donc il peut ya voir ben voilà
au moment où je parle effectivement moi
j'ai une image qui qui se coupe
ça peut arriver qu'ils aient des
coupures et là pour le coup c'est parce
p6 qui ferait de la censure speccy que
ça d'habitude justement de jouer sur ça
si jamais il y avait un échec
l'atterrissage du premier étage sur la
barge vaille le film ils ont même fait
des compilations de toujours leurs
échecs y surf là dessus en terme de
communication il n'y a aucun souci
donc voilà ces coupures elles sont elles
sont pas
elles sont pas volontaires c'est des
petits bugs qui peuvent arriver
donc on n'est pas loin fameuse barge
d'accueil d'allumage on a loupé le on a
loupé à l'opposé il s'est posé le
premier étage s'est posé un magnifique à
la ministre avant moi le moment où le
propulseur s'est posé on l'a raté parce
que tout simplement ça n'a pas été
retransmis c'est ça exactement donc le
propulseur a atterri sur une barge dans
l'océan en fait le premier étage a
atterri et est arrivé en fait comme la
fusée de tintin en marche arrière pour
se poser en pleine mer donc c'est un
c'est vraiment une prouesse
technologique exceptionnel
alors messieurs joli mais si je voulais
je voulais tout dans ces cas là il ya
des gens et j'en vois dans le tchat
même si le chat du film traite qui
disent non et spéciaux ils disent là si
on l'a pas vu et se tue en réseau tout
ce qu'on peut lire tout et en direct
donc on renverra les images elles ont
été filmées par les caméras automatiques
et donc non il n'y a aucun effet aucun
effet spécial c'est c'est vraiment très
complexe et donc il n'y a pas de souci
pas la peine d'y voir un quelconque
mascarade eux et donc alors ça c'est pas
l'objectif principal de la mission
souvent les gens sur les lancements
commerciaux s'arrêtent à ça la
récupération de laitages on le reste de
la mission est quand même loin d'être
terminée il faut se mettre sur orbite il
restait encore un peu près de deux
minutes et après rejoindre la station il
ya encore une journée de travail
mais voilà l'atterrissage et est un
nouveau succès à mettre au crédit de spe
6 sachant que la barge
elle est sur l'eau
un peu mobiles que là on a quand même
j'ai eu l'impression qui avec quelques
vaguelettes donc ça bouge donc osé poser
poser comme ça un engin de plusieurs
tonnes sur un petit point au milieu de
l'océan c'est ça reste même si c'est la
routine pour spe 6 toujours un exploit
comme tous les lancements de fusées de
façon vu les les puissances qui sont
mises en oeuvre en gilles parlé des
différents dangers qu'ils avaient bien
décollages de fusées on n'est pas prêt
de voir ça de manière
enfin la comparaison avec le avec
l'aérien et à ses limites
ah oui il faut voir quand même les
dimensions le premier étage c'est
quelque chose qui fait 29 m 29 mètres de
long sans intérêt tâche donc vous voyez
c'est quand même c'est un immeuble de
dix étages
c'est un immeuble de dix étages quant
aux le sa masse au décollage ses 270
tonnes globalement donc évidemment quand
il retombe
il est beaucoup moins lourd puisqu'il ya
plus du tout le contenu des carburants
et en plus il ya plus tout ça mais on
comprend bien quand même que c'est
remarquable toute cette structure là se
pose sans trop se déformer centraux
s'abîmer dans un contrôle absolu en fait
donc trente mètres de haut ça reste
quelques quand même quelque chose de
très très imposants on voit sur les
images ces combinaisons heures
elles sont très légères et on voit bien
la casse alors on voit aussi je sais pas
si vous avez les mêmes images parce
qu'en fait selon selon les flux il ya
des petits décalages de quelques
quelques dizaines de secondes entre le
live de spe 6 et la nasa s'est pas les
mêmes
les mêmes timing et nous non plus mais
moins l'image que j'ai là on voit donc
la pièce internet âge qui a été larguée
donc les deux astronautes sur orbite
la première partie de la mission est
donc parfaitement réussi comme je disais
à la deuxième tentative et un report à
cause de la météo donc c'est quand même
très impressionnant et je pense que le
président trumps il est arrivé à kennedy
va surfer sur sa dans un discours qu'il
était censé faire après la confirmation
de ce succès et qui va peut-être signé
le début d'une campagne électorale qui
repart à après le coronavirus donc
america is back lunch américain a envoyé
ses skis et ce qui est écrit c'est
vraiment le slogan est là ça tombe à
point nommé pour une campagne électorale
de 14 minutes on suit ça avec vous c'est
un plaisir de pouvoir suivre ça avec
vous il y actuellement 40 milles plus de
quarante mille personnes sur le table
qui me suivent un grand merci à vous de
suivre cet événement avec nous sur ce
direct direction lisf alors j'ai regardé
un petit peu le la fréquentation des
différents sites
puisqu'on s'attendait à ce que ça soit
les états unis attendaient ce ce retour
un équipage américain lancé depuis le
sol américain allait d'un véhicule
américain depuis neuf ans donc c'est
vraiment un événement très important
et là effectivement on voit sur le site
de la nasa j'ai pas vu pile au moment du
décollage mais il y avait quasiment 2
millions 2,1 millions de personnes
connectées sur le site de spe six
avaient presque 4 millions de personnes
connectées pour un lancement une
retransmission de 2,2 lancement
demeurant direct c'est que c'est assez
assez phénoménal et puis nous nous avons
culminé à 53 mille personnes ce qui est
ce qui est pour nous un record je sais
pas si gilles tu as déjà fait autant non
moi personnellement c'est un record 51
millions de personnes en live pour
l'atterrissage de fil à est quand même
sur la comète c'était un grand moment
européen et français
donc on a fait plus que ce prêt 6 ça
nous est arrivé mais bon c'était une
autre histoire spatiale et messieurs
nous sommes à 15 minutes maintenant
poste décollage nous parliez tout à
l'heure il de 19 minutes avant de devoir
de pouvoir en tout cas à percevoir la
fusée au sud de la france tire de 10
degrés au dessus de l'horizon
ça montera jusqu'à 29 degrés au-dessus
de l'horizon donc c'est quand même pas
très très haut dans le ciel vers le sud
ouest
et ça c'est un drap ça passera dans
l'ombre de la terre vers 18 degrés sud
sud est
cinq minutes après vous voyez c'est très
fugace ça traverse le ciel comme ça de
manière un peu tangente entre 23h11 et
23h16 pour la station spatiale
et effectivement quelques minutes après
on verra donc crew dragonne la capsule
habitée avec ses deux occupants alors on
verra pas les deux occupants par le
hublot mai mais on verra un petit point
blanc traverser le ciel le ciel de
france
donc paris vers 23h cells oka l'onu
aucun danger à l'oeil nu ou jumelles si
vous voulez mais aucun danger à l'oeil
nu
c'est c'est très beau à voir
alors j'ai petite perte de signal la sur
ma source quelle agence de presse ap je
vais juste changer votre petit instant
d'un sommet juste changé de sources un
tout simplement
désolé pour ceux qui contretemps voilà
sachant qu'en direct sur les décident de
la nasa et de spe 6 ils sont passés aux
conférences de presse commentaires et
compagnie il ya plus d images live de la
capsule bien c'est peut être pour ça que
agence de presse ap un couple annonce la
retransmission ça ne leur semble pas
d'habitude c'est beaucoup moins brutale
que ça mais ils ont peut-être pris de
court très court et aussi voilà donc sur
les deux sites cités c'est le patron de
la nasa là qui est en train de répondre
aux qui fait un premier commentaire à
chaud et où on imagine le discours qui
qui qui là est très enthousiaste sur le
retour de l'amérique la place du privé
avec un enthousiasme à ces débordant je
dois dire mais normalement sur le chêne
de la nasa
il devrait y avoir une couverture la
nasa avait promis 24 heures de direct
donc il devrait y avoir de temps en
temps peut-être que là ils laissent les
astronautes se déshabiller ou attendre
peut-être une orbite avant de se
déshabiller je sais pas s'ils gardent
leurs combinaisons ou pas je n'ai pas
vérifié en tout cas il n'y a pas de
module orbital
quand les russes emmène des équipages
vers la station avec le vaisseau soyouz
ils ont un vaisseau en deux parties la
partie au décollage où se trouvent les
équipages c'est le module de commande
comme le vaisseau crew dragon ou avec
les banques est où sont installés des
équipages et les commandes de vol et
puis une fois que le vaisseau est arrivé
sur sur sur orbite temporaire on peut
passer dans le module orbital pour aller
se dégourdir les jambes
enlever son scaphandre le faire sécher
mais ça c'était quand les vols durer
deux jours avant il fallait 48 heures
pour les sérieuses pour aller à la
station depuis quelques mois le soyouz
est capable de rejoindre la station en 6
heures
donc maintenant il ne se sert plus du
module orbital le dragon lille mais pas
6 heures il va mettre entre 19 et 24
heures je vous disais mais en tout cas
il n'a pas de module orbital dont je ne
sais pas si les astronautes vont se
déshabiller en tout cas il ya des
moments où clairement au couple la
caméra pour qu' il soit il est un petit
peu d'intimité il est prévu donc je
crois que c'est gilles ou stéphane qui
disaient qu'il y aurait dans ce télé
frédéric pendant qu'ils disaient qu'il y
aurait une simulation de reprise en main
manuelle des commandes par les
astronautes
avant l'amarrage demain qui lui doit
avoir lieu de manière nominale en mode
automatique
auparavant les astronautes vont faire
normalement est live en direct sur nasa
tv qui devrait être retransmise sur pas
mal de réseaux sociaux alors messieurs
nous n'avons plus les images en direct
je vous propose quand même de terminer
par par quelques questions auxquelles
nous n'avons pas encore répondu pas tout
puisqu'elle a eu beaucoup et de de
toutes sortes par exemple accord qui
nous montrait précisément quelle
température dans la capsule un je ne
sais pas si on peut la donner au degré
près mais qui fait froid est ce qu'ils
les choses que c'est climatisé
comment ça se passe dans une capsule que
celle-ci ses fans alors les capsules
sont climatisées donc il fait à peu près
l'air ambiant après on se retourne
vingtaine de degrés pourquoi qu' il faut
pas être trop tôt parce que ta
collection plus mal et donc ce sens sera
pas bien et faut pas non plus les
surfaces trop froid parce que c'est pas
grave du tout pour le tout pour
travailler
donc en général c'est qu'une matrice et
variées
donc ya pas problème
on allait aussi une question qui est
revenue régulièrement concernant les
combinaisons je pense c'est une question
mitroll me réel mais je pense que
beaucoup de gens ça pose en vrai comment
comment ça se passe s'ils ont envie
d'aller aux toilettes
qu'est ce qu'ils font ce qui revient
quasiment à chacun de ses lives fusée
foule faut le savoir vous le soir pierre
françois oui j'avais dit qu'on ont
préparé ce live que je réponds à cette
question parce que j'ai produit à 4 ans
maintenant un petit livre où il ya la
réponse qui s'appelle comment on fait
pipi dans l'espace c'est un petit b
stellaire des questions les plus
fréquemment posées aux astronautes et
des réponses sérieuses avec des dessins
rigolos alors sur le le crew dragon je
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas de
module orbital dont il ya pas de
toilettes et donc a priori des
astronautes vont faire comme du temps à
paulo comme quand on est en sortie
extravéhiculaire en fait comme quand on
est engoncé dans un scaphandre et ben
c'est la méthode camping
couches-culottes enfin tout ce que vous
voulez mais des toilettes nomades d'yvon
ils ont des couches comme des bébés
et voilà donc ccc à la guerre comme à la
guerre
une fois qu'ils sont à bord d'une
station en revanche il ya des vrais
toilettes
hélas les toilettes se fonctionne comme
sur terre avec la différence que sur
terre la gravité fait que tout va au
fond de la cuvette et que dans l'espace
si vous n'avez pas un système aspirants
il peut y avoir des titres des petites
surprises donc les toilettes sont
équipées de d'aspirateurs donc il ya
pour les hommes pour la petite
commission il ya des embouts individuel
et pour les femmes aussi et puis pour la
grosse commission
c'est une scène un peu plus petit que
sûr que notre lettre sur terre
inspirante et puis après tout ça est
stocké pendant quelque temps dans des
sacs hermétiques mis dans les vaisseaux
cargo automatique qui amène
régulièrement du fret et qui quand ils
repartent vont être précipité dans
l'atmosphère pour brûler les serbes
vide-ordures économique puisque tout
brûle et ça fait des belles étoiles
filantes donc le pipi des astronautes
chimie en étoile filante
c'est beau non c'est très positif
question 2 et madame tout le monde à ce
stade là est-ce qu'ils sont déjà en
apesanteur
alors il ya quelques minutes on le
voyait encore on les voyait encore
attachés à partir de quand est-ce qu'ils
sont en état d'apesanteur j'enterre dès
que les moteurs se sont arrêtés ont fait
ils subissent plus l'accélération
fournis par les moteurs et donc quand
ils sont quand ils ont sans cette phase
satelliser autour de la terre ils
peuvent aussi se détache flotter dans
l'espace est coté dans la cabine en tout
cas et avoir cette sensation d'absence
de poids je suis entré en même temps là
je reviens un petit peu dans le passé
par contre faut que je mette un bong
l'ip lait parce que sinon les gens nous
rejoignent vont croire que le décollage
a pas encore eu lieu mais plutôt que
montrer des conférences qui sont pas
forcément très intéressante en tout cas
en anglais en tout cas c'est but de cela
est si vous êtes anglophone évidemment
n'hésitez pas mais là l'idée c'est de le
faire en français donc je remets d'image
dili a déjà quelques dizaines de minutes
maintenant ce sera plus intéressant pour
répondre à ta question je vais mettre un
petit panneau ripley pierre françois
veil ajouter quelque chose oui
simplement frédéric a dû nous quitter il
faut éduquer et journaliste radio et
d'un après le lancement il ya quelques
commentaires à faire donc il a dû partir
rapidement il nous salue il a passé un
bon moment il espère surtout que des
gens qui sont en face de l'un de leurs
écrans et qui nous ont écoutés ont
également passé un bon moment
je l'espère en tout cas ils étaient
nombreux ils sont toujours nombreux à
poster dans leurs commentaires
commentaires sur le fait que malgré
l'absence l'absence d'image désordre
désormais aussi c'est incroyable de
pouvoir de pouvoir vivre ça ont
lourdement beaucoup aussi le le but la
mission de se voir ce qu'on peut refaire
un petit un petit mémo banque n'était
pas là au dip ce live on l'a dit en tout
début de ce live les deux astronautes
qui sont partis qu'est-ce qui vous faire
dans l' iss
alors bac en fait la mission aujourd'hui
principal s'est testé le nouveau
véhicule la nouvelle cabine
donc l'objectif c'était la mission en
orbite
ça c'est réussi la prochaine étape c'est
demain 16h30 l'amarrage à la station
après les astronautes vont rester à bord
de l' iss avec les trois cosmonautes qui
sont déjà à bord ils vont rester entre
un et quatre mois en fonction de
justement l'état de du vaisseau donc on
va qu'on va surveiller ou pendant sa
période d'amarrage régulièrement voir
comment ils se comportent et puis après
il y aura la dernière étape ce sera de
rentrer sur mer c'est un émérite et un
amerrissage son parachute et après en
plein milieu de l'océan qui est aussi
gilles l'expliquer une phase de très
très délicate avec beaucoup d'énergie en
jeu et de risques inhérents à une
rentrée atmosphérique
donc l'objectif s'est testé ce vaisseau
une fois que les astronautes sont à bord
en sécurité à l'intérieur de la station
et qui vont séjourner entre un et quatre
mois ils vont devenir membre à part
entière de l'équipage 63 et ils vont
donc mener des expériences participer au
programme quotidien des astronautes à
bord de la station donc des expériences
autour de la physiologie de l'étude du
corps humain
la mécanique des fluides de l'astronomie
que sais-je de plusieurs laboratoires
américains japonais et européens qui
sont rattachés à la station et les
astros travaillent huit à dix heures par
jour sur des expériences qui est à
l'absence de pesanteur y avoir aussi des
sorties à priori benkan devrait sortir
avec son l'autre astronaute américain
qui est qui et à bord en ce moment parce
que la semaine dernière un vaisseau
cargo japonais cette fois à année à la
station de nouvelles batteries
le dernier de quatre lots de six
batteries donc 24 qui doivent remplacer
elles sont deux fois plus performante 48
anciennes batteries de la station
donc ces six dernières batteries il va
falloir les sortir du cargo est allé les
installer sur une poutre à l'extérieur
de la station et ça ça se fait en partie
avec un bras articulé mais les
raccordements finaux ses désastreuses
qui vont devoir sortir en scaphandre et
c'est une épreuve puisque c'est des
sorties qui dure entre 7 et 8 heures
c'est extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
lent extrêmement préparer en piscine
répétées et donc c'est des astronautes
en général quand une belle expérience
qui qui qui on confie cette tâche thomas
puisqu'elle l'a fait fait des sorties
luca parmitano également c'est un moment
c'est la mission dans la mission assez
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau quand on
est l'astronaute mais c'est pas tout le
monde qui peut faire des sorties
ce qu'il faut
or c'est qu'en général les moteurs ont
fonctionné un régime bien déterminés
c'est assez difficile
ça existe un ace ça on l'a vu par
exemple sur le module lunaire le lem
apollo on pouvait réduire la pousser à
la moduler sur un moteur fusée
relancèrent classique en général le
moteur fonctionne un régime nominal et
dans change pas la fusée va certaines
démarre assez lentement mais on a dit
que les astronautes pouvaient subir une
facteur de charge de 3 à 4 g parce qu'en
se dit dans les biens le lanceur va être
plus léger et donc d'accélérer
même si le moteur fonctionne fonctionne
à régime constant
donc c'est et puis on souhaite pas non
plus partir trop lentement pour ne pas
être trop sensible aux perturbations qui
pot que pourrait subir le lanceur dans
l'atmosphère et puis ce qui se passe
aussi c'est qu'on on espère sortir le
plus rapidement possible de l'atmosphère
pour gagner en vitesse
c'est clair je pense que c'est clair ce
qui était très clair c'est que du coup
j'ai eu un problème de son j'ai posé la
question je demandais à jean pierre
elkabbach a répondu je posais la
question de zacharie pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut autant de puissance pour pour
faire décoller des fusées prend on les
fait pas qu à l'horizontale tout
doucement comme dans l'est comme les
films et alors on a aussi beaucoup de
questions et ça c'est peut-être plus tôt
pour gilles sur la les endroits où on
pourra voir ou pas la fusée je ne sais
pas si c'est si vous avez encore une
carte sous les yeux une trajectoire ou
demander ce qu'on pourra la voir depuis
la suisse est ce qu'on pourra la voir
depuis la belgique
est ce qu'on pourra la voir depuis le
québec voilà ce qu'on peut faire un
petit point
la trajectoire alors sa trajectoire on
pourra effectivement la voir depuis la
belgique et depuis la suisse sans
difficulté la capsule
je vous recommande en fait d'aller sur
le site event tirer about.com donc ch e
à ben s tiré à béhobie points comme ivan
stéréo bose
comme hélas vous tapez votre
localisation donc peu importe où vous
vous trouvez sur la planète vous avez un
système de géo coup oda qui va vous un
centre à lise en latitude et en
longitude c'est très facile à faire et
vous cliquerez iss ça se passe et
internationales et sur crew dragoni vous
aurez les éphémérides jour par jour pour
pour le lieu que vous aurez rentrée et
vous aurez donc toutes les coordonnées
heure de début culmination dans le ciel
et or de fin du passage de ces
satellites puisque finalement la station
spatiale et la capsule crew dragons sont
maintenant des satellites artificiels en
orbite autour de la terre
mais si on fait un petit peu dans la
technique on a ça qui nous manque dans
le château comment est-ce qu'une fusée
ou une capsule en l'occurrence avance
dans le vide
est ce qu'on peut faire en quelques mois
un petit cours de propulsion pour sa
grande émission d'obligations la
propulsion qu'est ce que tu veut se
lancer alors j'en viens alors si on
parle dans ce qui se passe c'est
concernés dans le ville il n'y a plus
rien qui vient freiner une fusée dont
qu'elle conserve sa vitesse donc déjà
d'une chose et ensuite pour faire
avancer une fusée canton
sur un chariot qui roule par exemple on
largue de la masse et puis on l'arc de
masse et puis on la largue rapidement et
plus on fait avancer la fusée dans
l'autre sens tout ça vient de ce qu'on
appelle la conservation de la quantité
de mouvement on perde la quantité de
nous vendre
dans un sens c'est ce qu'ont l'arc de la
masse avec une certaine vitesse ils ont
l'art gagnon l'a fait gagner à la fusée
pour compléter pour compléter les
questions précédentes en fait il faut
beaucoup d'énergie pour atteindre ce
qu'on appelle la vitesse de libération
vous avez en fait ma gravité 1 qui qui
nous retient tous sur la terre qui nous
attire tous vers le centre de la terre
en fait donc cessé depuis newton qu'on
connaît ce principe élémentaire de la
physique et qui est valable à peu près
partout dans l'univers c'est que la
gravité attire les corps et donc bannu
en fonction du corps planétaires sur
lequel on est elle elle est propre à
chaque corps planétaires sur la vue pour
qui là est justement pour les commettre
pour les astéroïdes par quoi la gravité
est extrêmement faible
mais ce n'est pas le cas sur terre et
donc pour s'arracher de la planète
il faut beaucoup d'énergie donc pour
transformer cette énergie en vitesse en
fait donc il faut aller très vite
voilà pourquoi on a besoin de fusées et
du coup en fait on parle pas
complètement la verticale si vous voyez
bien trait à chaque lancement de fusées
bien on part au départ à la verticale
c'est assez lent au début mais on
accélère et finalement on prend une
courbe très spécifique très mesuré très
calibrée très pointues pour pouvoir
atteindre cette vitesse de libération et
se satelliser juste en dernier point ce
que j'ai oublié de ce que j'ai oublié de
dire c'est que pour créer cette quantité
mouvement on utilise de la chimie c'est
à dire qu'on chauffe des gaz qui sont
qui deviennent très très chaud
condé temps dans une cuillère et cc gaz
qui sont qui sont très qui sont largués
très
pidement qui ont une masse également
importante par rapport à la fusée qui
crée cette créé cette poussée qui crée
cette variation de quantité de mouvement
c'est une des choses dont on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé ces dernières années en
fait mais là les ingénieurs de spe six
ont réussi à mettre au point un moteur
très spécifique un moteur-fusée très
spécifique extrêmement performant
réutilisable qui probablement fait toute
la différence avec ses concurrents donc
l'inde est l'un des éléments majeurs du
succès de spe 6 c'est sans conteste ce
moteur en europe sur le chat qui nous
qui nous remercient
merci de ce que vous faites ou qui vous
remercions d'avoir d'avoir suivi ce live
je me trouve deux caméras en même temps
que je parle d'avoir suivi sur les cdo
qui vous remercions d'avoir suivi ce
live avec tout cet événement avec nous à
on termine maintenant la capsule
poursuit sa poursuit sa route vers iss
nous n'avons plus les images les images
que vous voyez en ce moment en direct ce
sont des images d'il y à quelques
dizaines de minutes avant le décollage
on va le va leur passer ensemble pour
ceux qui ont pour ceux qui l'ont raté en
continuant bien sûr à prendre vos
questions notamment cette question d'un
internaute dont jouit le non désolé ça
défile très vite une fois de plus ce
qu'ils étaient la taille de cette
capsule
à l'intérieur on a l'impression qu'ils
sont assez aller 3-2 je sais pas si vous
avez là la dimension exacte à
l'intérieur de cette capsule pierre
françois alors je vais vérifier
exactement parce que je les ai pas tous
par coeur le volume pressurisée ses neuf
mètres cubes 9,3 mètres cubes alors ça
peut paraître peu c'est pas énorme
si on devait y rester très très
longtemps mais c'est sensé le voyage est
censé durer 19 heures général je le
rappelle sont quand même des théâtres
autres qui sont habitués qu'ils sont
très très calme très serein et qui sont
habitués à rester un endroit sans bouger
effectivement un enfant de quatre heures
on va peut-être du mal à passer plus de
devenir dans une capsule comme ça à la
différence des autres capsules quand
même
je sais pas si vous avez fait attention
au moment de la préparation des
astronautes
avant qu'on démarre cela est fort ce qui
était déjà connectés les ninjas là les
techniciens qui préparait les deux
astronautes rentrée deux bouts dans la
station dans la capsule pour aider les
astronautes c'est quand même rien à voir
avec le soyouz où là on rentre un peu
comme presque de spéléologie à l'aller
les sièges sont moulés à la forme des
astronautes individuelle et il ya
vraiment très très très peu de place de
libre là ils sont que deux
la capsule pour accueillir jusqu'à 7
personnes et a priori on y rentre debout
après les sièges s'incline 1 ils sont
autorisés
ils peuvent ils sont baissées au moment
de l'installation et puis ils sont
remontés vers les écrans tactiles
donc a priori ça reste une petite
créature sahara est une capsule et 3 mai
par rapport aux autres capsules j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même une
capsule de de grande taille alors j'ai
pas en j'ai pas en j'ai pas cherché j'ai
pas comparer avec le starliner je sais
pas si le style l'honneur sera de la
même taille ou plus petit au plus grand
mais en tout cas le cros dragon et il a
l'air pas mal quand même
monsieur la carie vous remercie pour la
réponse que vous l'avez vous leur est
donné
tout à l'heure c'était la propulsion
sauf erreur si on se met encore une fois
ça va très très vite te remercie encore
une fois qu'il faut maintenant parce que
vous êtes très nombreux à nous suivre ce
soir alors je reprécise pour les gens
qui arrivent en retard que les images on
voit ici et on va revoir en fait le
décollage qui a déjà eu lieu ça y est la
capsule est en route dans les ss le
décalage s'est bien passé l'ag
rembobinez là on est à trois minutes je
vais me remettre le ténor ou gérants
robinet à 3 minutes avant le décollage
ou six tours minute pour les gens qui
l'ont qu'ils ont ratées on va pouvoir
voir en direct mais ne soyez pas surpris
si on est moins enthousiaste tout à
l'heure c'est plus que pour les gens qui
étaient là
nous avons déjà vu à ce décollage
en attendant tu vas prendre bien sûr vos
questions vos commentaires alors je me
tourne vers le vert le chat et je vois
cette question de marine concerne bien
sûr et qui nous demandent est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de risque de collision avec des
météorites ou des débris
j'imagine qu'évidemment tout cela ait pu
participer et préparé il alors a priori
les le risque encore une fois le risque
et à maîtriser au moins pour les débris
pour parce que les débris qui a des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
débris
on les connaît on les suit par des
radars notamment à des radars militaires
en fait qu' en fonction de leur taille
assure une cartographie extrêmement
précises de tous ces débris il faut
savoir que les débris les débris
tournent eux aussi en orbite autour de
la terre à 28 milles kilomètres heure
donc même un tout petit débris comme une
écailles de peinture par exemple qui
ferait moins d'un millimètre
donc quelque chose d'absolument
insignifiant sur terre à 28 km heure à
400 km
c'est un véritable missile en fait on
comprend bien alors imaginez des débris
plus gros donc les radars militaires
arrivent à suivre assez précisément des
débris de quelques dizaines de
centimètres voire même inférieur parfois
qui sont des résidus de vieux satellite
ou de vieille fusée ou de vieux étage
parfois même des astronautes qui lors
des sorties extravéhiculaires ou perdus
des équipements des boulons des marteaux
des tournevis des choses comme ça c'est
arrivé là en l'occurrence le risque est
extrêmement faible
il est pour courser débris là quant aux
météorites bien c'est pareil un homme et
et or puisque la météorite c'est là le
caillou une fois qu'il est connecté sur
terre quand il est dans le ciel c'est
encore un météore
bien là c'est extrêmement rare et il
faut comprendre aussi que les distances
sont très importantes
la planète terre est une grande planète
là c'est crew dragonne c'est la tête
d'une épingle dans une meule de foin
donc le risque est quasiment totalement
nulle pendant cette phase de transit
entre la terre et une orbite puis entre
l'orbité de la station spatiale
toutefois on sait qu'à bord de la
station spatiale il ya effectivement un
risque de collision avec des micro
météorites qui n'est pas nul hein c'est
pas nul et donc on en tiendra compte
et puis ça serait vraiment une malchance
majeur si ça se produisait avec une
météorite même un peu plus importante
qu'une micro météorites et pendant que
vous parlez gilles on revoyait le moment
du décollage je le rappelle jean qui
nous rejoignent vraiment à l'instant là
nous voyons les images en replay le
décollage a bien eu lieu à l'heure
prévue c'est-à-dire à 21h 22h française
toutes leurs nous l'avons suivi en
direct avec vous j'ai été là où on vous
leur passe tout simplement pour vous qui
n'était pas présent et on prend vos
questions et vos commentaires on est une
question qui peut paraître mais que je
trouve quand même intéressante et de
quoi est fait une fusée quels matériaux
en fait on utilise pour ressort une
fusée principalement c'est un matériau
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de dire où il
ya des matériaux particuliers pour pour
faire fonctionner une fusée vous êtes
amateur de résistance à la chaleur
j'imagine qu'il ya des débrayages qui
sont quand même un petit peu un petit
peu spécifique je sais pas si quelqu'un
a la réponse à cette question
jean-pierre la question est évident qu
est-ce qu il ya beaucoup d architecture
différente
on essaie pour résister à la chaleur
tout à l'heure on a vu par exemple le le
moteur du deuxième étage qui était rouge
qui part par les gaz très chaud qui est
expulsé par le par le moteur
vraisemblablement il s'agit de matériel
peut-être anti carbone
comme ça pour résister à la chaleur
d'autres solutions sont possibles sur
les moteurs de la navette par exemple
bien c'était des métaux soudés les uns
aux autres et on faisait circuler en qui
de dons pour refroidir la structure on
utilise beaucoup de métal sur le corps
de la fusée on va utiliser pour les pour
les véhicules de rentrer des matériaux
qui doivent résister à l'échauffement
très fort pendant la rentrée dans des
matériaux qui vont sable athée qu'est-ce
qu'on va utiliser d'autres de maître
avec composite aussi parfois sur des
corps de deux propulseurs à poudre pour
alléger la structure
donc c'est des matériaux qui sont
bobines et autour du corps du propulseur
et qui sont qui sont collés en fait en
sorte qu'ils sont plus légers que du
métal donc chaque kg gagnés sur sur la
sur le propulseur et qui va nous
permettre de gagner aussi sur les kilos
de charge utile donc c'est toujours très
intéressant d'être le plus léger
possible
et puis après il ya d'autres matériaux
pour la fabrication de tout ce qui est
par exemple à l'intérieur de la capsule
qui vont être votre également différents
mais qui serait difficile de lister de
manière exhaustive ici
[Musique]
décès sur trois environ 4,5 km de la
terre donc entre 400 450 régulièrement à
des ans et donc régulièrement à remonter
un petit peu mais une chose autour de
400 km de la terre c'est pas très loin
ses apparitions mais toute une énergie
folle hôtel pour pouvoir
oh
pardon avant de répondre à cette
question juste préciser complément à la
réponse de stéphane sur l'attitude de
lier cesse donc 400 kilomètres je
confirme le la capsule là au moment où
on parle elle elle se trouve à une
altitude d'à peu près 200 km elle est
deux fois deux fois moins août et donc
elle doit passer pendant les la journée
qui suit est là elle va elle va monter
progressivement pour rejoindre la
station elle est deux fois moins haute
que que l' iss sur comment voir là où se
trouve la station
alors gilles indiqué tout à l'heure
l'excellent site ivan second pour savoir
quand est-ce qu'elle passe au dessus de
de chez soi on rentre ses coordonnées et
on a les prévisions jusqu'à une semaine
en avance pour savoir où se trouve la
station il ya plusieurs sites sur google
ou fait qu rentrent le cache un ss et là
en général on tombe sur le site de la
nasa
et il ya une carte du monde et on voit
on voit la trajectoire de la station on
peut voir si elle est d'ailleurs au
dessus de la surface éclairée ou ou non
de la terre et ce qui permets de vous
rappeler que dans la station l'adieu de
la durée du jour ne dépasse pas 45
minutes puisque une station à 28 km
heure à 400 km d'altitude
mais 90 minutes à faire un tour complet
de la terre donc le soleil se lève et se
couche ce soit par jour à bord de la
station et les astronautes vivent à
l'heure de moscou de manière
complètement arbitraire puisque le jour
se lève c'est un etc de la lumière
artificielle à l'intérieur et d hugo qui
permettent de recréer de la nuit quand
il faut se coucher
alors si je peux rajouter quelque chose
de très sympathique mais alors qui va
être très très compliqué à avoir c'est
que demain soir la station spatiale
internationale passera devant la lune
très rapidement il faut ça dure un
pouillème de seconde
sur une bande transversale qui
traversera le sud le sud sud-ouest de
l'île de france
donc les habitants de buc les habitants
de saclay de vauhallan de palaiseau donc
c'est une diagonale comme cela verini
jouy en josas verrons s'ils ont de la
chance très précisément à 22h26 04
secondes et bien transité la station
spatiale internationale devant way
devant la lune
merci pour ces précisions qui je pense
vont ravir beaucoup de nos internautes
parce que c'est vraiment ce que c'est la
question qui est le plus revenue ce soir
c'est où est ce qu'on peut voir la
station où l on peut voir la clape ce
qu'on peut la voir depuis la france
depuis la belgique depuis la suisse
effectivement je pense que vous et faire
quelques quelques heureux
puis alors il ya une autre lyotard une
question mais la nôtre
autre commentaire qui sont venus
régulièrement tout au long de la soirée
alors pas mal pas mal par des par des
trolls mais sans doute peut-être que
certains étaient très premier degré
drogues dures en slice et sur la
question de la courbure de la terre est
plate et l ronde et on est encore à cary
je crois qu'il a formulé sa souvent de
questions tout simplement et qui nous a
demandé est ce qu'on peut avoir la vie
de justement de deux spécialistes de
connaisseurs de ce domaine
dans ce débat qui que vous le savez sans
doute messieurs agite énormément les
réseaux sociaux est ce que lutter veut
se lancer dans ce débat faire françois
moi j'ai pas d'être d'avis à donner
simplement juste renvoyé les gens sur
l'image qu'on voit à travers les hublots
depuis les astronautes déjà à 200 km ils
ont une vue qui porte sur 3000 km et qui
montre déjà une belle rotondité de la
terre et plus ils vont monter à 400 la
différence sera pas importante mais
quand on a marché sur la lune
on a bien vu à quel point la terre était
parfaitement ronde presse et toutes ces
théories du complot ou plates east moi
je ferai pas de commentaire sans plus de
commentaire alors difficile de faire
sans plus de commentaires ce que
évidemment le moindre action se
déclenche toujours attendu à tant de
commentaires mais voilà pas tant que ça
car il était avec nous depuis depuis
très longtemps sur ce live est toujours
avec nous et peut-être qu'il aura la
réponse entre l éclairage qui donne
envie voilà ma vie de connaisseurs je le
rappelle vous pouvez renvoyer zachary
aristarque de samos
voilà qui qui avait déjà démontré que la
terre n'était pas plate trois siècles
avant jésus-christ donc voilà ça fait
cinq mille ans quand même qu'on sait que
la terre n'est pas plate
cinq mille hommes archives mais si on va
pas tarder à terminer ce soleil dans une
dizaine de minutes
je pense on va commenter sur l'extrait
rapidement peut-être juste à un petit
mot chacun pour pour dire pour les gens
qui vous qui ont suivi et qui vu ton
remercions et beaucoup de merci je
voulais transmettre évidemment dans le
chablais avez sans doute vu et su aussi
même si le défilé du sud très très vite
ou est ce qu'on peut vous est ce qu'on
peut vous suivre ou est ce qu'on peut
vous vous retrouvez chacun êtes tous
bien bien occupé j'ai peut-être est-ce
qu'on peut vous sur le constructeur mais
avec grand plaisir d'abord vous pouvez
retrouver la société astronomique de
france et ses commissions donc c'est une
une association en fait un reconnue
d'utilité publique fondée par camille
flammarion
donc on nous avons des commissions dont
notamment la commission astronautique et
techniques spatiales mais aussi tout un
ensemble de commissions thématiques pour
pratiquer l'astronomie les sciences de
l'univers les sciences de la terre les
sciences de la vie voilà et donc nous
avons un magazine qui s'appelle
l'astronomie qui parle en kiosque en
suisse en france en belgique et un peu
partout en france qu'aux phonie qui est
un magazine mensuel le seul magazine
mensuel en kiosques aujourd'hui qui
traite exclusivement d'astronomie des
sites internet des sites facebook nous
avons des tweeters aussi au g10 à milan
je me suis trompé ses 2300 ans mais
c'est pas tout à fait 5 millions mais je
pense qu'il ya 5000 ans vous savez que
la terre était ronde aussi mais on l'a
démontré ses arrêts star de samosas 2300
ans
je préviens je corrige voilà donc et
puis pierre françois aussi est
journaliste pour air et cosmos je le
laisse nous présenter son hebdomadaire
oui merci gilles voyer cosmos est une
revue
moins grand public qu'est un
hebdomadaire qui comme son nom l'indiqué
traite d'aviation et des spasmes moi je
m'occupe de la rubrique espace depuis
cinq ans les aspects techniques
commerciaux politiques de la conquête
spatiale
bon c'est d'abord un journal qui
s'adressent à l'industrie
mais bon voilà dès que les gens
commencent à en connaître un petit peu
sur le sujet et on rentre assez vite
dans le coeur du sujet donc c'est pas
vraiment pour les néophytes mais on est
comme on a été interrompue par le
courant d'un virus on revient en kiosque
a priori la semaine prochaine on a aussi
des informations qui sont peut-être un
peu plus large public sur notre site
internet
voilà les cosmos qui est qui est une
revue qui a été créé en 1963 par albert
ducrocq qui militait aussi au sein de la
société astronomique de france d'un
cancer et sa lola tous ces cercles de
passionnés se croiser
quand même régulièrement on a tous
plusieurs casquettes et on se retrouve
tous souvent autour de ses passions et à
l'occasion notamment de ces événements
il ya régulièrement des des rencontres
plus ou moins formel j'ai l'habitude de
deux d'animer des grands live qu'on fait
souvent à qu'il organise souvent la cité
des sciences en partenariat avec le cnes
ou l'agencé spatiale européenne pour les
grandes missions astronomique un
atterrissage martiens et compagnie
croiser âge de deux comètes et autres
événements astronomiques majeur on a
aussi des rendez vous un petit peu plus
en plus petit comité au sein de
commissions
et puis là-bas l'occasion faisant le
larron aujourd'hui avec avec ce beau
live et on a été ravie d'y participer de
vivre en direct
voilà sachant que personne n'avait la
possibilité d'aller en floride
moi j'ai assisté à la mission des mots
un don qui était la même mission mais
sans personne à bord il ya un peu plus
d'un an c'était en mars 2019 donc
j'étais à cap kennedy j'ai vu le
lancement j'ai vu de loin à 500 km de
distance dans la nuit laitages freiner
et se poser sur la barge
on a connu les risques d'orages qui
risquait de tout reporter le lancement à
la minute près puisque quand la station
passe il s'agit de lancer tout de suite
à la minute près sinon on perd 24 heures
mais là cette année enfin ce pour ce
lancement confinement oblige c'était une
poignée de journalistes qui ont déjà un
bureau permanent à kennedy qui pouvaient
qui pouvaient voyager ce sont leurs
france dessert plus la floride les
hôtels et étaient fermés donc voilà on
était ravi de le vivre de manière
virtuelle mais de partager avec avec
beaucoup de monde quand je vois qu'on a
été plus de cinquante trois mille j'en
suis encore abasourdi
plus de 53 millions simultanée tout à
l'heure au moment du pic effectivement
c'était à 21h22 vous pourrez bien
évidemment revoir revoir tout ça en vie
plein sur sur la page sur youtube pardon
sur la chaîne youtube du financement la
chaîne figaro live sur le site du figaro
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne youtube ça vous a plu parce que
on enfin d'autres on en faisait déjà
avant d'ailleurs peut-être que certains
d'entre vous étaient déjà là avec tout
quand on avait suivi
il y à il ya quelques quelques
maintenant quelques années même le
l'épopée de thomas pesquet on le sait
fait en direct alors pour ont diffusé
plus tôt sur facebook à l'époque
aujourd'hui ont diffusé sur youtube donc
n'hésitez pas à vous amène à la charge
de 10 et pourrait manquer aucune des
prochaines des prochaines diffusions en
live on a plusieurs personnes qui nous
parlait notamment des sorties spatiales
c'est des choses qu'on a déjà diffusé
donc peut-être eux on en diffusera
diffusera dans les jours les semaines
qui viennent on préfère les diffusant
des mobiles construction des sondés
français forcément à l'espace on est on
est un petit peu changé mais si vous
insistez on pourrait tout à fait
diffuser des futures sorties spatiales
des astronautes de lier 16 y en a une de
deux prévus vous l'entendez tout à
l'heure vous ajouter quelque chose eh
bien peut-être qu'on pourrait faire la
diffusion du retour sur terre de nos
deux astronautes
par exemple par exemple ça se passe
quand ben on n'a pas encore la date mais
on le saura on le saura probablement
dans l'est dans les jours ou dans les
semaines qui viennent donc peut-être
dans quelques semaines peut-être dans un
mois un mois ou un peu plus oui comme si
c'est entre 30 et 100 10 à jour c'est ce
qui est annoncée aujourd'hui par la nasa
on verra après l'amarrage ça sera un peu
plus précis voilà c'est pas avant un
mois j'ai j'imagine avant un mois de 0,2
vous est précieux c'est moi c'est toi
avec le toujours avec plaisir
on va embêter soleil maintenant je ne
peux pas terminer ce live ça ont demandé
une dernière fois agile de repréciser la
question que tout le monde se pose que
ce coup encore total 25 à l'instant sur
le tchat
comment voir la capsule depuis la france
comment voir les ss de la france et à
quelle heure est ce que pour faire un
dernier petit point le sujet fait le
poids ce soir la station spatiale 23h11
entre 23h11 23h16 direction ouest et sud
ouest
et puis quelques minutes après 23h16
23h18 crew dragonne à peu près la même
la même direction ouest sud ouest à 10
degrés entre 10 et 20 degrés au dessus
de l'horizon
mais demain demain vous aurez à nouveau
la possibilité de voir la station
spatiale à 22h23 est pareil là ça va
durer presque six minutes donc on va
vraiment voir la station spatiale
pendant six minutes traversé le ciel où
on a vraiment de la chance parce qu'en
plus on anticipe lot de magnifiques donc
là la station sera beaucoup plus haute
dans le ciel
le premier joint également 23h13 pareil
trois minutes pour l'avoir traversé le
ciel toujours vers l'ouest ouest nord
ouest ouest sud ouest
et puis crew dragonne coup dragonne n'a
pas encore évidemment l ensemble de ces
paramètres mais ce soir 23h16 à 23h18 et
demain soir 23h17 à 23h18 à peu près au
même endroit à l'ouest ou au sud ouest
10 degrés au dessus de l'horizon donc
c'est quand même assez bas c'est pas
très très haut dans le ciel pour la
capsule
mais la station là on a de la chance
c'est beaucoup plus haut dans le
merci beaucoup
messieurs peut-être dernier petit mot de
jean pierre de 2 des femmes stéphane oui
oui on verra ce qu'on m'a dit tout à
l'heure sur la première chose qu'on
ferme les deux astres en arrivant sur
dix qui vont faire quelque chose de très
symbolique puisqu'ils vont aller retirer
un autocollant qui a été laissé par
l'équipage de sts 135 le dernier vol de
la navette pour congeler 2011 et sur
ceux sur ce que l'on remarqué que cet
autocollant est à prendre par les
prochains d'astronautes ces partis ont
juste à l'américain avec un véhicule
américain
donc voilà ses chaussettes la première
chose que doit faire s'est retiré cette
banderole cet autocollant pour n'en
marquer complètement la symbolique de ce
vol jean-pierre un dernier tim robbins
et direct moi c'était juste pour vous
remercier tous de nous avoir suivis et
puis de tout ce que vous avez fait pour
promouvoir pour nous aider à regarder
vers le ciel
dieu merci beaucoup merci également à
merci et moi à dominique était là avec
nous durant tous tout ce live et surtout
un grand merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis et donc je vous le disais
abonnez-vous la chaîne youtube si vous
regardez sur youtube abonnez-vous figaro
si vous nous regardez sur le site
directement du film où on vous dis à
très bientôt pour toute l'actualité en
direct l'actualité spatiale et pas que à
très bientôt
au revoir